thank you all for joining us this
afternoon we're excited to have today
with us Dr Sheldon Campbell from Yale
School of Medicine to be presenting on
influenza Diagnostics just a couple
housekeeping tips ahead of time in the
lower left but uh corner of your screen
you should notice a c button and then
below that is a green Q&A button if you
have any questions that you'd like Dr
Campbell to answer during the
presentation or afterwards please go
ahead and type them in by pressing the
green Q&A button now and then you can
enter your questions and we'll answer
them during the Q&A at the end of the
presentation you can click the C button
in the lower left corner in order to be
taken to the page to get your CE credits
and this webinar is approved for one
pace credit or if you're in Florida for
the Florida credits and for anyone who's
uh attending just everybody go ahead and
click on that and fill out the form and
you'll get your C
credits Dr Sheldon Campbell is associate
professor of laboratory medicine at Yale
School of Medicine and he's the director
of clinical laboratories for the VA
Connecticut healthare system he obtained
his bachelor's degree in biology from
Rice University in Houston Texas and
completed both his MD and PhD degrees in
the medical scientist training program
at Baylor College of Medicine which is
also in Houston
he was a resident and postto fellow in
the laboratory of medicine at the Yale
School of Medicine and is board
certified in clinical pathology and
medical
microbiology Dr Campbell is director of
clinical laboratories and medical
director for chemistry microbiology
mobac teriy and point of care testing
for VA Connecticut and he also has a
role in microbiology and chemistry
specialty areas for the New England
veterans Integrated Service Network
Laboratories Dr Campbell is the director
of the Yale Medical School medical
microbiology and infectious diseases
course and Yale Winchester Medical
microbiology fellowship program Dr
Campbell's research interests include
education of pathology residents and
medical students point of care testing
HIV testing and cost-effective clinical
microbiology practice so once again if
you have questions please remember to
enter them into the green Q&A box in the
lower left corner and with that I'll
hand it over to Dr
thank you um so um the I think this is
probably a timely topic it's almost flu
season and everyone's um embroiled in
Ebola but we're going to have to
distinguish our rule out Ebolas from flu
and so you can count this as part of
your Ebola preparedness
activities I'm going to talk about flu
Diagnostics and 2014 um and this is such
a rapidly changing area that who knows
if it'll be any good in
2015 okay
um um so the the topics I'm going to
cover are what is influenza um and how
can you protect yourself and your family
and then the bulk of the talk will be on
testing for influenza methods rapid
tests and um focusing on molecular
methods hopefully
for almost
everyone um the word flu gets tossed
around a lot people say they had the
stomach flu um but it's not the stomach
flu right that was probably neuro virus
or a bad oyster influenza is a primarily
respiratory disease caused by the
influenza virus um there are influenza A
and B viruses a is more common but both
cause seasonal flu and both are um
serious illness L
es um in the United States somewhere
between 5 and 20% of the population gets
flu every year more in um pandemic years
like 2009 Less in some years it it goes
up and down in ways that we don't
necessarily understand all that well um
but it results in 200,000
hospitalizations and between five and
20,000 deaths each year from influenza
so it's not just the
flu worldwide influen is a disease of
tremendous Public Health importance 3 to
5 million severe cases and 250 to
500,000 deaths per year from
influenza um symptoms of influenza and
if you're in paying attention to um
Ebola you'll discover that there are an
awful lot of similarities here um
include sudden onset of fever headache
extreme tiredness dry cough sore throat
runny nose muscle aches and often
gastrointestinal symptoms nausea
vomiting and diarrhea which are more
common in children um and we're seen in
up to a quarter of the cases with the
2009 pandemic strain in 2009 so while
influen is primarily a respiratory
disease um it certainly has systemic
symptoms and even some um GI
symptoms seasonal flu traditionally is
most dangerous for the very old the very
young and persons with severe underlying
illness so this is mortality from flu um
over um over over the age range and you
can see it's the highest in children
under one year old persons over 65 that
does change a little bit when we have
something like a pandemic um typically
in with outbreak strains and novel
strains it's actually young adults who
may suffer the most from influenza
because of um a severe immune
inflammatory response to the the
virus so there are ways that you can
protect yourself simple precautions and
vaccines we get influenza via the
droplet
route these are
droplets um they are coughed out or
sneezed out by a person with with
influenza uh they float around for just
a short period of time then they land on
surfaces and typically we get influenza
by touching a surface with our hands and
then touching mouth nose or eyes and the
virus gets in through that round we
don't get influenza by kissing pigs um
except if it's a really bad date um but
for the most part we get it through this
droplet
route so um coughing sneezing and then
touching the droplets on yourself on
another person or on a droplet without
washing in your
hands I'm still learning this thing
forgive
me so during the flu season wash your
hands often with soap and warm water
especially after you cough or sneeze um
wash for 15 to 20 seconds that is a
surprisingly long time it's sort of the
length of time it takes to saying happy
birthday to you twice um the other
option is to use alcohol-based hand
wipes and shelf sanitizers they are also
effective against the flu
virus um other things you can do is to
to help protecting yourself and protect
others cover your nose and mouth with
the tissue when you coppers knees and
then throw the tissue away after you use
it don't carry it around like I often do
when I have a cold um and forgot to
bring enough tissues with me um in your
pocket get rid of those tissues as soon
as you're as soon as you use them
uh avoid touching your eyes nose or
mouth this is a very difficult thing to
do uh most of us touch our face several
times an hour um you if you are sitting
there and trying to be conscious of this
you'll discover that a minute from now
you'll have forgotten and touched your
face and avoid contact with sick people
this means um you know when when
somebody is sick and coughing and
hacking around you avoid contact it also
means that if you're sick avoid contact
with well people so um convince your
employer that yes it is a good idea for
you to stay home to avoid infecting
everyone around you um keep your kids
home from school if there's any way you
possibly can um keep these keep these
viruses in their
place so if you're sick stay home and
until you've been symptom free for 24
hours and if you're sick limit your
contact with other people as much as
possible
there are some warning signs of um more
severe illness associated with influenza
um for most of us it's a a disease that
we will recover from relatively easily
at home but um emergency warning signs
that mean you should seek Immediate Care
include difficulty breathing or
shortness of breath pain or pressure in
the chest or abdomen sudden dizziness
confusion severe persistent vomiting and
flu like symptoms that improve but then
return with fever and a worse cough
that's often a sign of a bacterial super
infection um that can be very
severe similarly in children rapid
breathing or trouble breathing a bluish
or gray skin color not drinking enough
fluid severe persistent vomiting not
waking up or not interacting
irritability not wanting to be held flu
like symptoms that improve but then
return with fever and worse cough if you
see any of these in in adults or
children um that's a time to contact
your your doc or um if they're very
severe take the patient to the emergency
room
immediately so I have a polling question
here we're trying to do this fancy um do
you plan to get your flu vaccine this
year let me push this out to the
audience and give a give give yourself a
chance to um answer answer this question
let's see how good you
are so I'm pushing these results out
about 80% of you plan to get the flu
vaccine this year about
33% um
don't the the seasonal flu vaccine is
very safe um most reactions to the flu
vaccine are local tenderness um there
are a few serious reactions they usually
represent allergy to the egg based
vaccine components that's why we ask
everyone before we give them the flu
shot if they have an egg allergy and
there is no association with guon Beret
syndrome this has been looked at very
carefully over the last um decade or so
and patients who get the flu vaccine are
no more likely to get guret than people
who did not get the vaccine and they are
much less likely to get um influenza
they are much less likely to get
um the flu and serious complications of
it there are two types of vaccines the
flu shot which is what most of us get um
it's a killed virus so there's no live
virus in that flu vaccine at all um
there's um single dose for most of this
two doses recommended for children from
zero to 9 years old and there's a high
dose a double double strength dose for
persons greater than
65 there is also a nasal spray for
people who don't want to get the the flu
shot if that is a live viral vaccine um
it's an timul uated live viral vaccine
and it is not for persons with
underlying disease or family members of
those because it can actually spread a
little bit from person person it's
unlikely too but we like to be
safe none of the flu vaccines contain
any form of adant there's no thimerosol
there's um no no substance other than
some flu protein um in these
vaccines so um I urge you to get your
flu vacc and to get um your family
members and people around you vaccinated
it is the best way to prevent influence
or infection um and the the so people
say well I got the flu vaccine but I
still got the flu and that may well be
true the flu vaccine is about 70 to 80%
effective in preventing
influenza um but there's also just a
whole swarm of other vaccines that cause
similar illnesses um and so it doesn't
protect against the other viruses and
that's why even if you are vaccinated
it's important to wash your hands well
um stay home if you're sick and so on
there's lots of information on the cdc's
website about flu vaccines and about
ways to stay
informed so enough of that on to flu
testing which is what you're here for
the main methods for um testing for
influenza are culture DFA or direct FL
fluorescent antibody testing rapid
antigen tests and um a whole host of new
molecular tests for
flu so let's do another poll before the
pandemic what were you using for flu
testing nothing rapid antigen culture
DFA or a molecular test give you a
minute to um answer this
poll I think it's interesting to see how
we have evolved over time on our
practices in this area hardly any area
of medicine has changed more in the last
decade than has diagnostic
virology lots of people
answering give it just another minute
because people are still putting their
answers in
here and I'll send the results out um
about a quarter of you were doing um
nothing um that was not uncommon back in
in 2009 um what a lot of people weren't
doing any testing um most people were
doing if anything a rapid antigen test
about
60% um a few sites
um about 7.6% doing culture a few doing
DFA and about 10% in 2009 were using a
molecular test for
influenza so to put flu testing in
perspective here's how it gets
used if the a p person tests positive
for for
influenza with a positive
test what happens is we tend not to
start antibacterials because it's the
flu it doesn't need need antibacterial
therapy um antivirals may be used the
for best outcome they need to be started
within 48 Hours of the onset of symptoms
um the and the treatment is of modest
value for influenza um it decreases the
duration and severity of illness lets
people go back to work earlier it's not
what you'd call Curative but um it is of
of of some value against
influenza um patients who get a positive
flu test will be put on droplet
precautions if they're admitted to the
hospital and some other tests may be um
eliminated the consequences of a false
positive test are potentially severe
because you might not treat a bacterial
pneumonia you might not even diagnose a
bacterial pneumonia you might not do the
proper um um testing to diagnose a
bacterial pneumonia or another serious
systemic illness speed is helpful in
this because we have to start antivirals
within 48 Hours of onset um but
specificity in flu testing is essential
um a flu test that is not specific that
gives false positives is a potentially
dangerous test and so whatever else you
think about your flu testing it has to
be
specific flu a versus flu B
dis discrimination sometimes matters
because um at least before 2009 our H1
m1s were almost universally Tamiflu
resistant that changed with the 2009
pandemic strain and now it's susceptible
again but we'll probably have resistant
strains come along
again with a negative flu
test we will consider giving
antibacterial therapy because it's
probably something else we don't start
antivirals we don't do drop up
precautions and we'll do further
diagnostic studies to try and establish
the um idology of the disease the
consequences of an error here are
moderate um we may overtreat with
antibacterials um we um may miss the
opportunity to Institute droplet
precautions in an in impatient which can
um lead to spread of influenza um but
we're not going to undertreat a serious
illness so sensitivity while highly
desirable in a flu test is perhaps not
quite as essential as
specificity and so that's kind of why
the rapid um antigen tests are viable
flu culture and DFA I'm not going to
spend a lot of time on they're used
primarily in high complexity settings
they require um skilled staff um DFA is
a relatively rapid test takes one to two
hours of Hands-On um and incubation time
the sensitivity from the top centers for
a DFA approaches culture but is a very
demanding technique to do DFA well for
Respiratory viruses it requires a
fluorescent scope and it requires staff
that are very good both at at performing
and at interpreting the fluorescent
antibody
slides culture can give you a an answer
in 24 to 48 hours um in and the with the
newest methods the culture is fairly
sensitive but relative to molecular
tests probably is not quite as sensitive
it used to be the gold standard probably
no longer
is rapid flu tests um for many years
have been the most widespread available
tests they're fast um minutes from
sample to result they're very simple
some of them are Clea waved require no
equipment however rapid flu tests sort
of up um despite occasional Publications
to the contrary um the sensitivity of
the best rapid flu tests runs in the 50
to 70% range and may run lower than that
in adults um who who tend to shed fewer
flu
viruses this figure is a convenient
sample of the recent literature um right
before the 2009 outbreak um and um
selected by Medline surge and what I
could fit on a single page and the the
key here is that the sensitivity of
these rapid tests relative to either
culture or some molecular method um
varies from a low of
47.7% to a high of
85% um the specificities generally are
quite good um the comparator um assay is
important molecular comparators are
really the gold standard culture are a
little bit less so but none of the rapid
tests are very
sensitive um the problem is that in many
places um for a long time it wasn't
rapid flu versus culture or rapid flu
versus a molecular test it was rapid flu
versus nothing because anything else was
quite complex um and there is some
evidence to suggest that if the choice
is between a rapid antigen test and
nothing at all that the rapid antigen
test does have some positive impact on
care um an uncontrolled study in the VA
hospital system looked at the use of
Rapid antigen test in older adults and
um uh the the positive predictive value
of fever plus a cough increased from 32%
to 92% with a positive rapid flu 20 out
of 22 patients with a positive rapid flu
and symptoms received antiviral therapy
compared with only 8% of patients with a
negative rapid
flu this is not a controlled trial um
it's really a a descriptive study um but
this is at least soft evidence to
suggest that if the choic is between
rapid flu and nothing that a rapid flu
test does have a
role um however rapid flu tests really
do not perform well this is a a simal
study from Christine jio's lab uh on
Long Island during the
2009 um influenza pandemic um showing
that in their hands the binax now uh flu
A and B test was only 9.6 sensitive
versus uh U either culture or PCR um the
3M rapid a plus b was 40% sensitive um
but neither performed at all well
against the 2009 pandemic
strain if you're going to use a rapid
flu test um you should make sure to
educate providers on specimen collection
U these tests require a lot of material
to be positive and a good specimen is
absolutely
essential test only during the flu
season um because um remember calling
false positives is a disaster in flu
testing and if you do testing when there
is no flu in your population all your
positives will be false
ones test early in illness because flu
is shed in the largest amounts then and
you can intervene then and make sure
that your providers understand the
results make sure that they understand
that this is an insensitive test and
cannot rule out
influenza there's some interesting um
literature on the use of Rapids buyer
and travelers um to rule out in or to
rule in influenza and decrease
antibiotic usage and usage of
antimalarial drugs um all that's fairly
soft and not really um highly relevant
to laboratory practice in the
US so make sure that um if you do a
rapid flu in your laboratory or or if
you oversee the use of a rapid flu that
you put a comment with the result that
you remind providers that these tests
are insensitive that out of season false
positives outnumber true
positives and that um um there may be
known sources of error some um of these
flu samples
are um have a problem with um bloody
samples it's also highly desirable to
provide supplementary testing um for at
least selected patients um you're more
compromised patients and for offseason
or early season positives which may be
false positives so have the ability to
provide a molecular test for patients in
whom making the diagnosis of influence
is essential or or in whom false
positive results are
possible so I have another poll here
what are you doing for flu testing now
send that one
out
so um here are the results of that I
think um fewer people are doing nothing
more people are doing molecular test but
still a very large fraction of the um
population of the of the laboratory
attendees out there are still using
rapid antigen tests and I think that's
um appropriate that's what we kind of
thought was happening but um uh be aware
of the limitations of those rapid tests
and and try to mitigate them by good
communication with your
providers and I think the rapid antigen
tests are or should be on their way out
because there are now um molecular tests
that are becoming as simple as as rapid
antigen tests not quite there yet but
getting
there molecular test for influenza can
give results in an hour or so with
real-time PCR
methods as a class they exceed culture
and sensitivity not because culture is
not good but because viruses fall apart
and die and transport but their new CLC
acid
remains um the detection properties of
molecular tests do vary from system to
system they have moderately to very
expensive equipment associated with them
so there is a bit of a barrier there to
implementation there are as far as I
know no Cleo waved um molecular tests
yet but some of them are moderate
complexity and certainly not at all
complex to run molecular tests now are
clearly the gold standard in flu testing
um for the next few slides my
information sources are a a listing of
molecular assays from the CDC the
College of American pathologist website
for some pricing information and
manufacturer website and PubMed for
pictures workflow and other
information so here are the FDA approved
molecular influenza tests as of about a
week ago um the air I flu A and B the
seent expert flu the e sensor
respiratory viral panel the filmarray
respiratory panel the IIs Plexi flu
which seems to be off the market so I've
grade it out the ium leot influenza ab
prodes profu and profast the kidel
molecular influenza A and B ass the
kyogen Artis influenza AB rotor Gene kit
the Simplex of flu a b and RSV and flu A
and B and RSV direct and influence a H1
in1 um sets of of tests the verene
respiratory virus nucleic acid tests and
the xtag respiratory viral panel in RVP
fast of all of these only two were FDA
approved in 2009 so this is an area
again that's really moving rapidly and
so stay tuned maybe they'll ask me back
to talk in
2015 um the first in alphabetical order
is the air I flu A and B um it's the
most recently approved of the molecular
flu tests moderately complex 15 minutes
to result um a little sort of toaster
sized instrument involved here um the
workflow involves bringing the supplies
up to room temperature put the test base
in the sample receiver onto the
instrument and allow it to
warm place a swab in the sample receiver
and mix it in um apply this little
transfer cartridge to the sample
receiver move the transfer cartridge to
the test base close the lid and let the
test run for 10 minutes and then the
instrument will interpret flu a flu B um
or both detected or um an an invalid
result seid's um expert flu assay
detects flu A and B and then
discriminates the 2009 H1 M1 strain um
it's approved for Naser andal swabs
aspirat and washes is moderately complex
the list price is about $50 per
cartridge the instruments for the sepian
range from 25,000 to
$175,000 depending on capacity and it's
about an hour sample to answer the
workflow is to take the the sample from
your your viral transport media U put
300 microliters into the large hole put
the binding reagent into another hole um
insert the cartridge and start the
acid the e sensor respiratory viral
panel is one of the multiplex flu tests
um it detects flu a
um ah1 ah3 a209 H1N1 and B so it
subtypes the flu quite extensively um
gives in addition RSV and b paraplu 1
through3 human metan numo virus human
rhov virus and adov virus b c and e
strains um this is a highly complex
system um lists for $90 a test I
couldn't find the price of the
instrument um and it also requires a
separate thermal cycler and separate
extraction so a fair sub fairly
substantial equipment um requirement for
this um complicated High throughput
Multiplex acid um so the workflow of
this involves an offline extraction
reagent prep um uh thermal cycling PCR
um digestion with an exonuclease and
then a detection step overall 6 to eight
hours um the biofire film array
respiratory panel is a another one of
the multiplex tests um detects a whole
swarm of human respiratory viruses um
and in addition three bacteria bord
Telesis micoplasma pneumoni and camodo
pneumoni it's approved for MP swabs and
is moderately complex it's a pretty
simple test to do and the list price is
$129 per sample and the instruments run
about $40,000 each with a sample to
answer a time of about an
hour so for the film array you insert
the pouch into the loading station
inject the hydration solution into one
side and the sample into the other side
of the instrument add the pouch to the
film aray and start the
run the ium leot influence AB assay um
the is from ium ium recently been
acquired by ro and leot stands for lab
in a tube it's a little um roller tube
with reagents on it that as the reagent
as the roller goes along the reagents
get squashed into various reaction
Chambers um it's a simple test for flu A
and B approved for NP swabs moderately
complex and Sample to answer about half
an hour and as you can see from the the
image here it is definitely being um
marketed not at the laboratory Market
but at the Physicians office office um
laboratory
Market um the workflow for the leot is
to add a sample scan the barcode insert
the tube and the results come out in
about 20
minutes the prodes profluent profast are
um real-time PCR methods from um prodes
which was acquired by H
logic um the prodes pro flu detects
influenza A and B and RSV and then the
profast is able to discriminate H1 H2
and 2009 H1N1 and there's also some
separate kits um available for other
respiratory viruses highly complex the
list price is about $45 for reagents it
requires extraction on a a separate um
extraction system and then detection on
uh the Sephia smart cyclone and is about
four hours sample to
answer the kaidel molecular flu a plus b
assay um is another highly complex um
assay for influenza A and B um approv
for NP and nasal swabs um requires an a
separate extractor and rtpcr system
either the seid Smart Cycle the applied
biosystems or the Life Technologies
Quant Studio it's about 4our sample to
answer so again another complex
multi-step um
assay the kyogen artist rotor Gene um
kit detects flu A and B um it's highly
complex approved for NP swabs requires a
separate extraction with a kyogen system
and then the rogene realtime
PCR the simplexa platform has got
several different flavors of influenza
assays that run on it um all from Focus
Diagnostics and
3M um the test detects flu and RSV and
then a separate test discriminates 2009
H1 M1 um and this is highly complex but
there's also a direct version that's
moderately complex and doesn't require a
separate extraction um that's all um all
runs on the the platform with a direct
sample answer so it's about four hours
for the the conventional and about two
hours for the flu
direct the verene respirat virus nucleic
acid test and RV plus kit is from
nanosphere um detects AB an RSV and B
the plus version also discriminates the
flu strains um it's moderately complex
lists for about $70 for the reagent I
couldn't find a price on the instruments
and sampled answer is about three and a
half hours for the
verene so the workflow is to load the
test cartridge and the consumables onto
the processor the processor processes
the samples and then the slide is taken
from the test from the processor onto
the reader for
resulting finally there's the xtag RVP
and RVP fast from luminex um detects a a
large number of respiratory viruses flu
RSV paraplu metan numo Rhino intvirus
and arbovirus and all of those except
for the paraplu on the RVP fast highly
complex um about eight hours sample to
answer for the RVP and about six hours
for the RVP plus this uses a a very
elegant um bead array technology to do
this Multiplex
detection so the workflow involves a
multitex Plex PCR and then for the the
conventional RVP um another enzymatic
treatment and then
binding um to the the bead array and
sorting and detection on the xmap
instrument um
so there's all this confusing array of
molecular tests and I'm not sure how to
help you sort out the the the confusion
um there are numerous studies of these
usually a single test versus culture or
two tests against um one another um I
didn't U I picked one simple example
just to show uh comparison of the verene
versus the simplexa um versus the
author's home brew PCR um this is a a
paper from the Jin Mican January 2013
and in this study at least the verene
was more sensitive for influenza A B and
RSV the simplexa um was not so sensitive
against influen of B I wouldn't take
this as a particularly as
a a definitive assessment of the either
system both neither one of them
performed as well as the author's
Homebrew test did um and the simplexa
test at least I know has been
reformulated somewhat since this um
study was done um so there's a lot of
literature on here but very little of it
um compares multiple
platforms just wanted to briefly mention
the performance of the air um the versus
PCR the Air's um sensitivity for
influenza A is about
88% specificity is very high as you
would hope um and at least in this small
study um the sensitivity versus PCR for
influenza B was
100% um one way to sort of look at these
assays is is to sort of look at um
complexity and speed and um ability to
Multiplex so um what I've done here is
I've graphed number of targets on the
the y- AIS and time to result on the
x-axis um the highly complex systems are
in yellow the moderately complex systems
are in green um in general the the there
are some quite rapid and quite um simple
tests that tend to be
um single Target or or two target flu A
and B AER iume expert flu um the leot um
the simplexa direct that give results
in 15 minutes to two hours the filay is
kind of an outlier because it's a a
highly multiplexed simple test that um
gives results in roughly an hour um and
then the um there are other tests that
are more multi multiplexed um that tend
to be um in the 4 to sixh hour range and
more
complex um the thing is that throughput
is kind of hard to figure out in some of
these tests the lower complexity tests
like the film array or the aier or the
ium typically test just one sample for
module the throughputs then limited by
the number of modules and the time per
test so for the um film array it takes
about an hour to run and you can so that
means you can run one sample per hour
per
instrument unfortunately and this is a
real issue in um flu testing flu testing
is low volume except during the season
when the volume expands hugely so
figuring out the economics and the the
um the operational aspects of flu
testing is a little complicated because
it's very very
seasonal the higher complexity test may
be harder to do but they're often done
in larger batches in batches of 24 or
more samples depending on the number of
targets and the capacity of the
real-time
instruments um so economies of scale can
make higher complexity complexity tests
um more um efficient per sample if you
do them in large
volumes um again Parson cost is
non-trivial for these um the cost per
test depends on the reagent plus
instrumentation plus labor costs um you
have to figure out how many single test
modules you need um you need to make
sure to count in instrumentation for
extraction if needed um reimbursement
for these is a moving Target it's not
something I worry about a whole lot at
the VA system so ask an expert not
me um but if your bean counters are
sophisticated people um which they
unfortunately rarely are
um the ability to to diagnose influenza
rapidly can move people through ERS
faster can um save um Hospital
admissions that are unnecessary that
there's a lot of potential for savings
elsewhere in the system with um
effective influenza
Diagnostics so let's do another poll
here do you plan to use a molecular test
within the next
year
I guess it's sort of a silly question if
you didn't weren't at least thinking
about it you probably wouldn't be um
listening to this webinar but silly
questions are important to ask too
sometimes
so you're you're pretty evenly divided
but it looks to me like about um 60% 55%
are planning to use a molecular test
within the next year note that that's
quite a few more than are using them
right now um and about 55% still are not
ready to pull the trigger on molecular
tests um one thing that can make flu
testing on a molecular platform um more
economical is to have other tests on the
platform so I'm just going to push one
more poll here um if you're using a
molecular test already do you have other
tests on that platform I'm interested to
know what the answer is going to be
there
so it looks like about um 55% have got
other tests on the platform and about
30% have only are only doing respiratory
testing on their molecular flu
platform um so that's just um one way
other way to to look at these and one
more complication to selling a molecular
flu test to your to your your
institution does it make sense at all to
test for the flu I mean the the
treatment for influenza is of modest
impact it's a disease with high
incidence but it's a disease with high
incidents over a short period of time
when people are coming in with the flu
lots of people are coming in with the
flu um this is a a coste Effectiveness
study um out of the anal of emergency re
medicine um that um assuming a $50,000
per quality adjusted lifeear willingness
to pay threshold um which is basically
the the number that people tend to use
the most cost-effective treatment option
is treatment according to P provider
judgment from 0 to 3% prevalence
treatment according to a PCR based rapid
test from 3 to 7% prevalence and
treating everybody at greater than 7%
prevalence um the big hole in this
analysis was that it ignored the fact
that you may induce any viral resistance
if you treat everybody um nonetheless
this is some evidence that at least
maybe during the the peak of the flu
season there is some coste Effectiveness
justification for um uh this this um
testing however you decide to test for
flu if you do um please instruct your
providers and Sample collection it's
probably the critical step in influenza
testing it's absolutely super important
if you're using a rapid flu which are
very insensitive tests but even with a
molecular test a bad sample means a bad
um result so influenza virus infects
ciliated respiratory epithelial cells
these are found in the naso fairings
they're found down in the lungs they are
not found in the throat a a throat swab
is a very very bad specimen for
influenza testing U most people use a
naso fenial swab you'll notice how far
back this goes it's almost to the front
of the ear ear L on the front of the the
patient's face um this is a a fairly
uncomfortable procedure but I've I do it
to myself every year teaching my medical
students um it should burn a little bit
um to get these specimens properly and
get the the the infected cells
um so um really train your providers
well um remember that false positives
have potentially severe consequences
like non-treatment of a serious
bacterial infection now some places that
are using highly specific molecular
tests are testing year round because
remember when it's summer here it's flu
season in the Southern Hemisphere and
influenza is transmitted year round the
tropics but um you need to be careful
about that um the it I think it's still
legitimate and maybe prudent to
primarily test during the flu season um
October through December or March um if
you have positives early in the season
very late in the season retain that
specimen for confirmatory testing
another option is to monitor Regional
influenza per your state or um CDC flu
maps and only start testing when flu is
reported in the area and finally remind
providers to test early in illness the
tests are most sensitive early in
illness when the virus is shed the most
and the best therapeutic results are
when the drugs are started early as
well so just to summarize molecular
tests are the emerging standard um
there's a variety of platforms and
formats um that can fit many Labs um
there are variations between the
molecular systems um specimen collection
provider education and testing only
patients at risk is essential and
prevention still is better than
diagnosis and treatment so get your
vaccine and wash your
hands so I have a song about the flu and
I'm going to turn control of the slides
over to Darcy but not control of the
video because I can't move slides
and
sing and Darcy I think you'll you'll
know when to move the
slides um and all of you sitting there
waiting to
um
uh I'm not able to do that according to
somebody let's see well okay I'll just
stop singing and move the
SL but I urge all of you sitting there
in your conference rooms um to
um sing along people will look at you
funny but that's all
right next slide this flu is your flu
this flu is my flu I get it from you I
give it to you so wash your hands and
wear your
PE this clue belongs to you and
me
um it says I can maybe move content
control to Darcy let's see if I can do
that
sorry we should have practiced this part
try that
okay it's
influenza comes from your
friend and we all dread it so please
don't spread it if you get a fever
you'll be a
believer
this flu belongs to you and
me this flu is your flu this flu is my
flu I get it from you I give it to you
so wash your
hands where your p
PE this flu belongs to you and
me it's on the road now it's string
somehow from nose to finger those fites
linger so wash your
hands cover up that speed a cover it up
this flu belongs to you and me this flu
is your flu this flu is my flu I get it
from you I give it to you so wash your
hands and wear your
BP this blue belongs to you and
me so close the
school the parks and play Grounds
reporters Bing like a pack of blood
hounds it's all around us so get your
flu
vaccine this flu belongs to you and me
this flu is your flu this flu is my flu
I get it from you I give it to you so
wash your hands and wear your
PP this flu belongs to you and
me this flu belongs to you and
me please don't give your FL to
me
so I think it's time for questions now
right let's see
here so there were several questions
regarding the flu vaccine can the live
version of the vacine give you the flu
um if someone is just tails off there um
the the live version of the the vaccine
can give you the flu only if that person
is imuno compromised um otherwise it's
it's um a very safe vaccine but you want
to only get it if you're immunologically
normal and if there's no one in your
household who could get the the the flu
from the live
vaccine um if someone is allergic to
feathers or eggs is there any risk to
getting the eggree version of the
vaccine sure shouldn't be um that should
not be a
risk what else might cause an allergic
response to a flu shot in a patient who
is not allergic to eggs latex or
therasol um I there there really well
there's no therasol first in the flu
vaccine that's very important to know um
I don't know what else there would be in
there that could um uh cause um an
allergy um people do have allergies the
most devious syncratic things but most
reactions to the vaccine are due to egg
allergies um can you speak to the
quality of the rapid flu test
particularly the readers like Sophia and
veror that claim they are correlated
directly with PCR tests um the the
Sophia and the veritor rapid tests have
been compared to PCR they are not as
sensitive um and I don't I don't think
anybody claims that they are as
sensitive as PCR
their their claim is that they are
somewhat more sensitive than the older
generation of rapid flu tests but um and
are still quite sensitive quite simple
to do I don't think they really approach
the sensitivity of PCR based tests um
however do you have any thoughts on how
long it takes to add these tests to our
clear
registration um I'm not sure exactly
what that question means um perhaps you
could um elaborate on that question a
little bit I mean in terms of
verification um flu testing is a pain in
the ass to verify because they um are
are the the the analyte is only around
for a short period of time your best bet
is to um work with a laboratory that's
got some samples saved for
you um Belinda contact me offline for a
copy of the song
um is it necessary to run other flu
testing if the rapid testing is negative
um it depends on what you want to do
with the
answer um if if you have a patient who
is at high risk for for serious
influenza for whom you're likely to
provide
therapy then it probably is necessary to
run other flu testing if the rapid is
negative some places use the rapid sort
of as as a a rule in if the person is is
positive then you say they've got flu
and and manage them appropriately if
it's negative then you look for some
other other
cause um the problem is of course that
sometimes the cause is still flu if the
rapid is negative um so it really
depends on the setting a lot of of
facilities are um saving the more
expensive molecular flu test for
inpatients or patients who are going to
be admitted and compromise patients and
um that's a reasonable kind of
strategy do I have New York hard any
hard data on a reduction in healthc care
spending if a molecular test is used I
have not seen um hard data the best data
I've seen is that cost Effectiveness
study from the anals of emergency
medicine
um for most people say people says Dr
balock where this thing is not behaving
flu vaccines don't prevent the flu but
actually increase the odds of getting it
the Mercury contained vaccines is such
an immune strong immune depressant that
a flu shot suppresses immunity for
several weeks this makes people highly
susceptible to catching the flu he says
they may even think the vaccine gave
them the flu but that's not true it
depressed their immune system and then
they caught the flu that is basically
um the um the um there
um either no Mercury or such a
remarkably small amount of mercury in
the flu vaccine I think I believe all of
them are are non Mercury containing
anymore that that there's no biological
plausibility to that people do often
talk about boy I got the flu shot and
then the next week I got the flu well
when do you get the flu shot you get the
flu shot at the beginning of the
respiratory viral season so people often
come down coincidentally with a
respiratory viral infection often not
the flu um uh during the shortly after
getting the flu shot there's no evidence
that flu vaccines increase the risk of
getting the
flu please elaborate on the note
regarding a negative PCR positive on
anything higher than 30 cycle thresholds
um that's um some data from the the air
poster um when the air was negative in
the PCR positive that was mostly in
patients with shedding very small
amounts of flu virus um greater than 30
Cycles on the real-time
PCR
assay do you really need to get a flu
shot if you never get the flu well I
don't know that you know that you never
get the flu do you never get a
respiratory illness at all I'm not
entirely convinced to by by people who
tell me they never get the flu um a lot
of people don't have severe illness with
the flu a lot of healthy people don't
get a real bad case of the flu and they
may just say they had a bad cold um but
there is still value to getting the flu
shot even if you don't get a severe case
of the flu because you decrease the
chance of passing that flu on to
somebody who is more vulnerable than you
and especially if you work in healthare
um I think it's really um an ethical
imperative to get the flu
shot um I don't have any other questions
that I can see here
um does
anybody have anything else to say we
have it looks like we've got 30
seconds I'd like to thank air for
inviting me to speak and I'd like to
thank all of you for um uh coming and
attending
e